[Music]
pree 5000 today we give in charity
fasting Ramadan Hajj is a pilgrimage we
see there's no god but allah and
muhammad is his final messenger the ones
I mean know it's a sacrifice but it's a
small price to pay for all the rewards
will give from my love
[Music]
so long were even what happened to later
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to salon studios today
will understand the house where you feel
at home I've got two honorable guests
here listen Charlotte brother hide that
so no more liquor and I've got my name
assalamu alaikum so as you guys know if
you know you're new to the house I'm
sure you new to the house here okay so
this has more relaxed more chose more
for young sniffing yeah yeah that's good
that's exactly the feeling we wanna
shout out so and also when I add on to
that drinks in drinks please Bob
complete bar bikini it's my drink slowly
guess what we have that yes here we go
so that's yours is Allah and that's what
yes okay and when you drink it please
the best not one here yeah so exactly
okay
okay what we'll do today is in Charlotte
really good Jesse and shadow home that's
what I'm gonna do is they youngsters
brought it as well include the
youngsters and that'll do 25 of you know
that young some are your and that age
range now will do you think I'm 20 okay
perfect okay yeah and you as well
okay so today's topic is how men fall in
love but the wrong way now when I see
this to you what comes to your mind when
I say to you okay this is today's topic
how men fall in love along with what
comes first
like I said before like the first thing
that comes to mind like let's say
illicit relationship will person of it
man a woman like it's something that is
something that you probably see
especially living in now and nowadays
which usually happens as well yeah
that's the first thing that pops with
the might anyway okay
putting into horror on relationships and
meeting someone in a way that Islam
doesn't permit yeah yeah okay if I told
you it's in a different way so for
example we know I just want our toes in
the Koran that we should tell the
believing men to lower their gazes yeah
so now obviously we live in a society
where women can dress up how they like
same with men as well and falling in
love the wrong way it's the reason I
mention this verse is because it kind of
connects to it there's a part to play in
both parts there'll be the man and woman
okay we have totaled over against all of
them tell us to know where our gates
just because women are dressed
inappropriately you should know your
gates by default new conception under
that Oh because you men are you know
perverse or whatever that's why women I
told it listen no besides all the
dresses even if she just is
inappropriate or appropriate we are
taught at our gate by default so that's
a misconception that we kind of live up
there but the question here is this a
lot of females a lot of sisters it
wasn't one non-muslim yeah they are
entrapped and actually I will call
shackles and the shackles of society
where you are told to dress a certain
way look a certain way where a certain
lipstick what every man this would Midd
as well for both boys so now what we
would understand is the psychology of a
man how he falls in love in the wrong
way now a lot of times a lot of sisters
might think you know what I need to look
a certain way or dress like this or
females in general for everyone actually
not just for Muslim females as well and
they believe that's dressing up and this
is something this is phenomena that's
happening now that then the less clothes
we have you know they use this phrase
unless it's best yeah the less clothes
that you have the more attraction you're
gonna get but what they fail to
understand is from my perspective is
that wearing less clothes you're gonna
get attention by default cause I'll go
tell us in the Quran for so said the
biggest thing that fell from oma is
woman now this does not mean women are
evil what this means is that we have a
weakness so for example a woman might
have a weakness towards shopping bags
yeah
it doesn't mean that bad he's evil it
just means it's just do weakness no but
I say so it's what a clarify was a woman
are some evil crazy yeah so we know by
nature a man's weakness is a woman so
now when a woman dresses up in a certain
manner she believes for example that
she's going to get attention yeah is
that the right attention because men can
fall in love the wrong way and that's
why a lot of woman get heartbroken
listen to this off you know what I
thought he loved me like I thought he
really and then she's used and abused
mister and then left if what is the
factor whoa
like if the sisters of oceans or a
female pushing this name as a male
yeah as a meal yeah
what's going wrong like to think about
lettuce is that going back to like a
young going back to Young metalli they
usually for each of you when I was with
my mates for that as well I'm gonna say
as it is as it is yeah if you see a
painting which is what they go get like
good looking good Buffy above nowadays
like yeah if you see someone like that
if you see someone like that's that's
just what attracts among OECD said women
for us is a 59 yes it's for us is that
we naturally attract energy at the
moment and obviously obligation to lower
our gaze
yeah that's that's what we that's what
to do but for if if a woman is dressed
up in the same way and I live this low
people have fallen into this as well or
manifold lentils well is that what ends
up happening is that when you see
someone who's very attractive very
attractive what the main the main string
and I know this is this is a lot of
people are friends I will I used to have
friends yeah that we had the same
mentality you see what we're looking for
is to get with this person yes don't
care about their feelings or anything
like that
yeah and they just want to if you know I
mean then just have exactly just have
just to commit or don't just want to go
into something I'll lust and exactly
some people might just see that woman is
an object [ __ ] that's having a nice car
and you want to show off your nice car
to everyone to make them think that you
have who's at fault here if we were
saying the female that dress up like
this
is it the Mayo's mentality that was it
because the fingers actually believe me
this is it's something that was
forgotten and we nearly really the
emphasis on this issue here as Muslim
men ourselves
we believe even if a woman's cause this
was the mentality of muffins yeah back
in the days watching his mom she's she's
dressed up like that oh she looks like
that she deserves me I'm gonna use her
bra look look
as a Muslim okay non-muslim or even if
you're Muslim and mentality as a Muslim
even if she doesn't respect herself who
told you that you need to treat to no
you should have been usually the right
thing you know and there's a no problem
I know that hundred law that it did come
across something like this where they it
was a marriage meeting over and the
person and obviously these the right way
to go back with a bully right but
because they're meeting for example and
he sense it's something from the female
that she's after something else
he will see it even told me was it to me
said even though I sense that like she
was kind of on that and I thought a bit
awkward I had to tell her my sister I
you know I'm not here for that and
that's how it needs to be not the
opposite way okay nice you know what she
sorry for saying she's asking for it I'm
gonna go and no you should be the better
person you should feel on scene you know
and this can actually change the
mentality you know what I was up for it
and this brother actually honored me and
respected me and corrected me yeah
instead of this other intelligible nah
she's gonna be like I'm gonna no you
don't do that you know it's like you can
you sing when a woman a woman together
in here by himself clearly said that you
know but lady says we should be
forbidding evil I'm doing good
we should be forbidden our ego by doing
something good in its place so if you do
if you DC a sister and you attracted to
her yeah you shouldn't demonize it into
an object you should see there's an
opportunity but you to do something good
by advising her
of course that's definitely true so one
time come up is that I was psychological
or sisters watching that female there
was one understand psychology area if we
see a film that that's the number one
first mission alone okay anyway but in
general for men you don't know is that
the reason they fall in love the wrong
way our sister or
females are watching is the fact that
they are witnesses like is it female
yeah so obviously when you dress up in
an inappropriate weight yeah that you
know increases their desires yeah okay
because this it's been rubbed in your
face and I'm not gonna give an example
of a cheeseburger and point woman as
they're not burgers yeah I'm not saying
that yeah the reason I'm saying is
because if somebody has information or
if someone likes eating something yet if
he's always rubbed in your face and made
little tractive it just enhances those
desires
I'm not saying once again woman huh I
don't know I really hate it yeah I'm not
using that exactly I'm not trying to
give an example but what it is is you
know they're female viewers is that
weapons is a man's desires he's there he
has a desire problem okay
and I was want eyelid ptosis told us
ways to attain that yet however living
in the society when a lot of females are
dressed up in an inappropriate way what
is this men tend to fall in love the
wrong way so what they do is they would
when they're speaking to you they say
I'm speaking they say I'm I'm I'm a bad
news and they say I'm a Muslim I'm bad
news I don't know Marchesa etc when I'm
speaking to you and you're dressed in an
inappropriate way automatically in my
head yeah I'm not even in my head it's a
Muslim trust me they think is that to
say bipolar
so now he's thinking the wrong way
because now we can see whatever it may
be yet and now his desires are flaming
up and he's thinking I want to commit
yes so this is this is where the crux of
the matter this is where the females get
that attention and think he likes me he
does like you he definitely does like
you but what does he like you for this
is a really important point here does he
like you for you or does he like you for
something else yeah
so this is where men fall in love the
wrong way so there was a statement that
I saw it it was a post made by someone
saying that we lower our gaze not
because you are not beautiful but we
don't want the following out the wrong
way now yeah so the thing is this is
what well I don't have a solid that's
what I'm lovin I love reveal something
to know your gaze and what does the
reminder to all of us you know you know
should increase in doing that inshallah
as well and it's really hard but I would
be assistance what you need to
understand is that when you look a
certain way you're dressed a certain way
you're gonna get attention but it's the
wrong form of attention and men will end
up falling in love I call it lost the
wrong way and because they come to you I
want to be with you for the wrong
reasons when they find someone better
looking with what you have to offer
they're gonna fall in love with that
person the wrong way and the cycle is
going to continue you know your
particular sisters from the I mean but
the issue is they also need to protect
their selves and the same with the
memory a communist teen female 2 the
only to blame no because it goes back to
what I said before we are total Iraqis
know based on how they're dressed
this is very cliche this is very
important here because I don't want to
be you know some you know are you
dressed up like this you deserve it no
talking about it so what you know what
every time you lower your gaze it's it's
always your benefits you could obviously
when you whenever you know your gaze
there is a reason behind it yes you
always three tiers of life because
obviously you can sit down you can sit
there do that but then enough there was
when you when you think about it and you
think well why I'm running like these
and the reason behind is to help you
increase taqwa yes yes I understand I
understand and to know no I'm doing this
because Allah is commanding me to know
my gaze he said to me if you don't if
you don't feel of them then say
something and it's much harder to know
your gaze with someone beautify
themselves makes it much harder to do
that yes by then compound it's gonna be
hot there's no excuse you know
don't even come close enough yeah now
some people think to yourself oh that
means I can kiss a cantar I can hog I
can do this this but as long as I don't
know what that means is brother
zina is there you don't go okay I'm
gonna vote round the other side of look
you don't see I'll go around it
this is the magnetic field and this is
really profound Alice Montella this is
the only similarity
and that's quite profoundly so what that
means is bah bah there's people that
means it can start with a case believe
me because when and this is a very
profound statement as well the heart
doesn't desire or the eyes don't see
this is quite profound
no-nobody desire something that it's not
you're looking at you can see so if you
never for example you don't know what it
is but once you taste it yeah and once
again I'm not saying women are
strawberries okay the fact is this I'm
talking in a design but once you taste
strawberry that one I would again and
again and again and once you bought him
chassis so the issue here is it's really
important for us and over on case
because it's the key to the hub because
that's where trust me
because and this is what happens you
know you know I've been listening to I
been sayin is true like no one's ever
going up to someone and had you know
without looking at them you know because
because we live cause we live in in
brain yeah we live in a non-muslim
country near the this all around us
yes yeah and obviously like you said
it's it's our obligation we have to
locate but then afterwards as days we
get short on the whispering
and it become it can become difficult
and not only is it not only is it like
it's out there because you can you can
stay at home though your whole life in
it no see
let's see anyway but then you have your
television yeah then you have your phone
and the Pantheon everything exactly and
it's social media now as well and we
come around disgusting things and so
it's probably at the moment uh
struggling at the moment yeah because
I've loved a lot of our was coming into
Islam yeah a minimum because obviously
living there leaving that life to join
to join him to drink alright so the life
of Muslim yeah yeah so it's difficult
and living in this country it makes it
difficult but um the murder
as we as we grow with people as we
increase ourselves in in in top wanna
understand why we do this
yes why we why we have to do this yeah
and why we have to lower case yeah
inshallah look Allah makes it easier for
us yeah that makes it easier for us but
100 like when it comes to this comes
when it comes this kind of topic and it
comes to this kind of stuff you know
nice it when he comes in a first
question like the question before we
talk about the blame who's to blame yeah
I feel like the main I think I feel like
obviously Bravo's insisted the deck they
poke this book they have played in both
parts yeah but like sisters sisters
sisters um and I'm almost saying like yo
go oh joy the whole saying that I'm
missing I'm not saying it's like I'm on
posting on them of course but the thing
is is that I feel like sisters it's just
me and understand that look if if you
are dressed in a certain weight a man is
gonna a man is gonna look yeah he's good
look because it's because it's weakness
Ram yes it is the weak this man that's
the that will happen yeah and obviously
for a man is like you you have to look
down look down you know you know should
have you shouldn't be looking at stuff
that you shouldn't be looking at yeah
but they get then then then it comes to
dilla comes the third blame I've been
the biggest pain that we have the moment
is is what society teaches yeah and it's
how women have been women
line and have been so sexualized yes
yeah they've been so sexualized and this
is what happens is that online ads and
promotional video now you see that's
what happens is that if cuz you know if
the Prophet didn't say something
actually I important to the people to
talk and so if you know this works
exactly and shall I do mention it but if
you can remember I that you can put out
the after that but if this was certain
with it so and also one thing that's
really important is that we do have
certain weather clothing like they cover
their self but I'll be honest some of
them they were tight and something do on
purpose so the question I need to ask
yourself is why are you doing that yeah
and there's some who maybe they can't
help it
yeah they just like that yeah but the
issue is is that some actually do it on
purpose yeah and sisters this is a
reminder to all of us is that you doing
that you're sinning because if you're
doing that what the intention stole that
meant to look at you who stand up and
end up falling in love the wrong way and
give me false promises and her you and
leave if you're doing that you're
sinning you've seen every person that
they should be lonely case but there's a
lot of men out there Muslim and
non-muslim and there's Muslims that you
know they don't follow it yeah you're
falling in your fallen see your phone
it's in two attracted towards them and
not only that you're gonna make them
fall in love with you the wrong way and
give you false promises I'll repeat
again
and you're the one that's going to be
hurt so let em and that's why one thing
that I really like about the whole point
of the hijab and is that you're covered
everywhere so when you're talking Missy
you can't talk the females by the way
this is like out of if you meet you yet
because there's whole thing of all women
are robots and when you see them you
hide behind the universe would you have
to be careful
this notion know at the time of Sahaba
for example woman that would would be
involved in treat yeah they would have
to haggle and the erotic niqab so the
person knows use a binder form even some
women revolve in battle like a bomb
exactly they go there's a lot examples
you can see yes so what was saying it
the fact about the hijab for example is
that when you if you speak into a sister
she's covered you you don't see nothing
but her face so you treat her I'm saying
you should treat every woman oh my how
they dress I'm just trying to make
leather
maybe the wisdom behind well Sarah she's
covered you can't see her chest wherever
wherever so now is that him this however
should be anyway but you you speak to
the face do you transition initially
important because the recent scientific
study that was done there were they
showed men women in bikinis a part of
the brain that lit up for to use it was
it was so he saw the woman as objects he
did not see them as humans do you give
Tennessee so now just to make very clear
we're not saying that you just treat and
respect woman to address I'm just trying
to say maybe the wisdom behind why that
is is because once they're covered up
fully you only seen the face so your
desires are not going to be and you
you're talking to her and you know
obviously people can argue is okay well
if it's a really attractive looking
woman and it's called a said you know if
you in that case we're in the car by
anyways that's it promises thank you for
watching from the house it was
interesting
hopefully you understand and insha'Allah
benefit from this video inshallah
problem sisters and inshallah for both
males and females all this one is all
the Jews to be modest you know and let's
keep that in mind and inshallah so you
don't fall in the trap of a man falling
in love the wrong way and maybe hurting
you know unless you guys assalamualaikum
so next time if there's any specific
total you wants to spoke of our comment
in the section below share it with your
friends and family so Michael slovis